let's get more now from our security and
defense analyst Professor Michael Clarke
so let's just start them with the two
men Xi Jinping and of course um Vladimir
Putin just tell us a little bit more
about the relationship between them yeah
at a personal level it's very good they
obviously like each other they've met
each other many times about 40 odd times
since they've both been in power I mean
Putin's been in power twice as long as
XU Jinping I mean he came to power in
1999 XU Jinping in 2012. but the
relationship is reversed between them
although they get on well Putin is was
The Hard Man and nobody quite knew what
Xi Jinping stood for when he took over
from hujin Tao in 2012 he removed him
nobody quite knew what he would be like
and over the years XI jinping's China
has got stronger Russia has got in a
sense weaker more aggressive but weaker
and now I mean Putin is now the weaker
of the two for sure and in a sense you
know Xi Jinping is now looking after his
client and his clients got himself in a
terrible mess in this crazy invasion of
Ukraine which is not going very well so
it's straining I think their their
personal relation because pragmatically
China has got a lot to lose from this
conflict as well as a few things to gain
given their relationship how far will
China go in supplying arms to Russia but
also what can we make of China's
proposal for peace in Ukraine yeah and
aren't I don't think the Chinese will
make a big play to supply Russia With
Arms because the cost of doing that
would be very great in terms of American
sanctions but they already are supplying
some arms they're helping North Korean
ammunition get there it's said that
about 240 000 artillery rounds were sent
not long ago they're sending dual use
technology components that can be
civilian or military so there's a
trickle of stuff which the Americans are
now are now chasing to try and sanction
the companies that are doing it
um I don't think that will get much
greater but it will keep on going I
think they'll keep Russia going
certainly with Precision Munitions or
Precision components for their weapons
on the peace plan Xi Jinping wants to be
seen as a peacemaker now he presented
this 12 point piece plan a couple of
weeks ago of those 12 points five of
them were actually okay from the West
Point of View from Ukraine's point of
view they would agree to them I'm sure
seven points are not because what the
peace plan really says is everything
should stay as it is in place which
means Russia gets to keep everything
everything gets conquered and if the
peace plan is accepted in six months
time and Russia's conquered more in six
months time it gets to keep that as well
so that's not no sort of Peace plan that
will ever be accepted but it's there
it's on the table and I'm Xi Jinping
hopes that at some point in the future
not now but maybe in six months or a
year's time people will come back to it
and say can you help can you do
something and then he will stand forward
as the man who has had a peace plan and
can actually lean on Putin to stop the
fighting that's the way he'd like to
present himself the man who basically
solved um the the the war then he'd like
to position himself so person then made
that surprise visit didn't he over the
weekend we saw some of those videos of
him driving around Mario Hall
um how has that been then seen in
Ukraine but not just Ukraine but also in
Russia yeah in Russia it seemed very
positively I mean this is Putin visiting
the front line you went to sevastopol
first of all in in Crimea then he went
to mariopol then he went to roster
London in Russia to talk to military
leaders that's inside Russia about the
whole thing and so that goes down well
in Russia and of course it's a way of
insulting the international criminal
court which you know looks at maripole I
mean of these children who've been
abducted a lot of them have been
abducted for mariopol so in a way going
there was even more sensitive and
manipal of course was was reduced I mean
it was a city of 400 000 people 350 000
left uh 22 000 have been killed ninety
percent of the buildings have been
destroyed or badly damaged I mean marry
Paul is a shell and he's going around it
as if somehow it's it's a sort of a new
build Milton Keynes well you know it
isn't